[Musica]
io io vi parlerò di progresso di
innovazione però quando si parla di
innovazione dobbiamo partire dal
presupposto che la difficoltà quando
arriva qualcosa di nuovo non sta nel
credere nelle cose nuove ma la
difficoltà sta nell'abbandonare quelle
vecchie che sono le nostre abitudini
Spesso i nostri modi di fare oggi dire
si fa così perché si è sempre fatto così
Vuol dire essere fuori tempo quando si
parla di innovazione Tra l'altro bisogna
anche Ricordarsi che l'ovvio di oggi è
sempre stato l'impossibile di ieri se io
fossi venuto di fronte a voi 15 anni fa
e vi avessi detto Guardate che un giorno
dentro le vostre automobili ci saranno
delle voci maschili e femminili che
sceglierete voi che vi guideranno a
destinazione dicendovi vai a destra vai
a sinistra la rotatoria prendilo al
secondo uscita la destinazione sulla tua
destra sei arrivato avreste detto e è
impossibile se oggi quel navigatore non
ci porta a destinazione come vogliamo
noi ci lamentiamo col navigatore perché
è ovvio esiste quindi deve anche
rivoluzionare io dico è ovvio col cavolo
è ovvio Perché qualcuno l'ha pensato
l'ha progettato e ogni giorno lavora per
cercare di renderlo perfetto e questo è
sempre un essere umano un uomo o una
donna ecco vedete l'uomo ha sempre
superato le grandi difficoltà e risolti
grandi problemi con Delle grandi
scoperte Tant'è vero che scopre il fuoco
poi scopre la ruota poi scopre la
scrittura secoli dopo fa anche una
grande rivoluzione la rivoluzione
industriale poi arriva la rivoluzione
digitale tutte queste grandi rivoluzioni
queste grandi scoperte hanno una
caratteristica il cambiamento che è la
costante della nostra vita e il
cambiamento cos'è che genera soprattutto
il cambiamento genera il futuro genera
quelli che sono i Trend del futuro e
allora adesso vi voglio parlare di quali
saranno i Trend i prossimi anni Beh
sicuramente la demografia il primo
l'economia globale la Geopolitica
l'energia la tecnologia e l'innovazione
ma partiamo dal primo la demografia che
è il driver che muove
tutto Che cos'è la demografia Beh
rappresenta la domanda mondiale
persone che domandano beni e servizi a
un sistema economico che li deve
produrre facendo utili e perdite che poi
è un sistema finanziario nel tempo
registrerà
Beh come si è evoluta la demografia nel
tempo intanto possiamo dire che in
questo preciso momento in cui io vi sto
parlando siamo 7 miliardi 954 milioni
769.7889 90 91 92 93 persone nonostante
guerre nonostante pandemie nella storia
c'è una caratteristica la popolazione
mondiale è sempre cresciuta e quella che
c'è si è sempre evoluta
quindi la domanda esiste ma genera
un'economia un'economia che sta
letteralmente cambiando vi voglio fare
un esempio perché potrei parlarvi di
tante cose ma in questo preciso momento
ognuno di voi qui o di quelli che ci
ascoltano può fare un acquisto online in
Italia ma si deve rendere conto che
magari il sistema di pagamento americano
e compro un prodotto che viene
fabbricato in Cina che viene poi
trasportato dalla Cina in Europa da
un'azienda Danese In un porto olandese
che poi un'azienda di Singapore porta
dall'Olanda all'Italia e poi un'azienda
tedesca ci porta sotto casa Ecco la
riflessione E cosa significa essere
globali significa che anche se non
voglio sono in un mondo interconnesso e
la Geopolitica sta facendo di tutto per
trasformare si sta trasformando ma per
capire cos'è la Geopolitica devo capire
il mondo in cui viviamo per noi viviamo
in un mondo Innanzitutto dove il 45%
della popolazione alla pelle gialla il
20% alla pelle bianca mentre il 20% la
pelle mulatta e il 15% la pelle nera in
questo mondo di oltre 7 miliardi e 900
milioni di persone ci sono
95 paesi si parlano 114 lingue si
professano 10 religioni ma Quara 59 di
questi 195 paesi in questo momento sono
in guerra e in questi paesi ci vivono un
miliardo e mezzo di persone
780 milioni di persone non hanno l'acqua
potabile in casa il 16% della
popolazione mondiale non parla non è
istruita è analfabeta il 20% del PIL e
in mano il 20% delle persone hanno in
mano l'80% della ricchezza però
5 miliardi e 200 milioni di persone
hanno internet e dentro fine anno
saranno 7 E allora qualcheduno potrebbe
dire ma è una tecnologia Certo
ma è un driver abilitante perché quando
arriva internet accade subito una cosa
alla geografia mondiale il mondo quella
notte in cui quel signore accende quella
tecnologia la rende disponibile a tutti
sposta una leva dalla posizione a la
porta la posizione B e accade questo
saltano i confini prima che essere di
Modena Emiliano
italiano europeo sono diventato siamo
diventati cittadini del mondo Oggi
possiamo
interagire socializzare formarci fare
affari lavorare per qualsiasi realtà da
qualsiasi parte del mondo senza dati
senza confini e spesso anche
gratuitamente quindi internet non è una
tecnologia un nuovo mondo che affiancato
un vecchio mondo un mondo però che è un
altro grande tema il tema del clima e
quando si parla di clima spesso il clima
viene affiancato alla parola
sostenibilità però perché la
sostenibilità sia concreta
È ovvio che ci deve essere la
sostenibilità ambientale Ma ci deve
essere anche quella economica quella
sociale e quell'imprenditoriale se non
rimane una mera illusione Ecco io vorrei
farvi alcuni esempi perché mentre c'è
qualcuno che parla c'è qualcuno che in
silenzio i problemi li risolve sempre un
uomo o una donna si Sta riducendo le
missioni di CO2 da una parte dall'altra
parte Ci sono aziende che stanno
costruendo sistemi per catturare la CO2
Ci sono aziende che stanno producendo
concimi affinché la terra catturi la CO2
Ci sono aziende che stanno lavorando
sullo spreco alimentare si dice che non
c'è abbastanza cibo per tutti Non è vero
ce n'è in abbondanza e che da una parte
viene sprecato e dall'altra parte non
c'è e grazie a internet questo domande
offerta viene messo in comunicazione e
questa cosa scomparirà molto più
velocemente di quello che non pensiamo
ma c'era un altro aspetto molto
importante L'aspetto della coltivazione
abbiamo scoperto l'importanza della
terra con questa pandemia del coltivare
me ne stanno nascendo le Vertical Farm
le coltivazioni verticali che non
sfruttano più terreni
ma sfruttano sistemi verticali e
ottengono un altro risultato Perché
Dov'è che viene prodotto normalmente il
cibo nelle periferie nelle campagne Ma
la concentrazione delle persone
prevalentemente nelle città e allora
parliamo di km 0 Ma come è possibile km
0 è possibile perché noi abbiamo
migliaia di edifici
alla malora che possono essere
riconvertiti all'interno delle città in
queste realtà e qualche d'uno lo sta già
facendo si stanno già costruendo questa
realtà l'altro grande driver l'altro
grande mega Trend ce lo diceva prima è
l'energia si dice alla domanda Qual è la
cosa più importante per la vita di un
essere umano si risponde sempre la
salute credo che sia ovvio ci rendiamo
conto che senza l'energia oggi viene
messa repentaglio anche alla salute un
ospedale non funziona non funziona un
mezzo di trasporto non funziona nulla E
allora parlare di energia significa
avere una grande attenzione Sì sulle
rinnovabili e le rinnovabili sono di
vario tipo Certo si sta lavorando Però
anche alla fusione nucleare entro il
2050 dovrà essere e dovrà essere
rispetto ai piani
industrializzato a disposizione di tutti
Ecco grandi cambiamenti che abbattono i
confini ma è sempre un essere umano
farlo questo cambiamento poi la
tecnologia un altro grande driver Che
cos'è la tecnologia è un'abilitante di
tutto questo fa parte della nostra vita
ormai Quali sono le tecnologie che
impatteranno di più sulla nostra vita
nel futuro Beh sicuramente
l'intelligenza artificiale la stampa 3D
la robotica la mixer Reality La Human
interface piuttosto che di fronte a
un'opportunità ci sono anche sempre i
problemi La vita è come una medaglia e
allora stanno nascendo aziende di Cyber
Security per portare queste questi
prodotti questi device ad essere sicuri
la blockchain per certificare tutto ciò
io oggi si parla anche di metaverso
Che cos'è il metaverso una parola che
tutti dicono ma poi si fa fatica capire
che cos'è le vedete Io l'ho semplifico
molto le persone possono leggere un
contenuto vedere un contenuto ascoltare
un contenuto oppure essere il contenuto
dentro il contenuto è un nuovo mondo che
si sta creando che non si può ignorare
perché già oggi nel 2022 400 milioni di
persone lo stanno frequentando
tutto questo genera innovazione Che
cos'è l'innovazione per me per me è
semplicemente la risposta a una domanda
che si fanno persone Uomini e Donne se
la fanno spesso nei momenti di
difficoltà che domanda si fanno le
persone quando hanno una difficoltà come
faccio a risolvere questo problema
quando arriva la risposta a quella
domanda sarà sempre qualcosa di
innovativo Ma poi
quell'innovazione deve trasformarsi
inevitabilmente in progresso e lo fa
quando quell'innovazione arriva Nelle
mani delle persone comuni migliorandogli
la vita allora io amo dire che siamo di
fronte In questo momento anche se non lo
vediamo a un nuovo rinascimento un nuovo
rinascimento determinato però da oltre 7
miliardi e 900 milioni di persone perché
mai come in un momento come questo un
numero così elevato di persone si sta
ponendo domande per risolvere grandi
problemi
e le risposte stanno già arrivando
Questa è aver fiducia nel futuro non
credere in qualcosa di esoterico ma
credere nell'essere umano Perché Perché
il futuro sarà Green e qui Vi voglio
fare esempi di innovazione e Green è un
acronimo Vespa per genetica robotica
internet intelligenza artificiale
nanotecnologie stanno pervadendo ogni
settore della nostra vita la quantistica
che sta entrando dentro ai computer e la
generando computer quantici che sono
molto più veloci degli altri computer
tradizionali ma oltre che elaborare dati
sono in grado di generare nuovi scenari
e quindi cambieranno ulteriormente ogni
nuovo ogni settore
Ma gli innovatori non sono solo
oltreoceano ce li abbiamo anche noi in
Italia pensate questa è una storia
bellissima di un ingegnere meccanico di
Brescia
che grazie alla contaminazione
con le nanotecnologie sviluppa la più
grande innovazione in campo edile
dell'ultimo secolo un intonaco di 2 cm
che rende antisismica una casa fino a
2,5 G pensate che il terremoto
dell'Aquila è stato di 0.50 Quindi
significa che con intonaco rendo
antisismica la casa ha un terremoto tre
volte quello dell'anno e se la casa è
terremotata in caso dell'Aquila 65%
delle case inagibili oggi non sono
collassate per poterci tornare dentro in
una settimana la intonati e la rendi
agibile Questa è una rivoluzione non
solo un'innovazione una rivoluzione
anche sostenibile e un'altra azienda
italiana sviluppato nel tempo 7 anni fa
una vernice con la capacità di catturare
gli inquinanti atmosferici
ma in piena pandemia di fronte un grande
problema hanno abbattuto e sono andati
oltre un confine con l'università di
Firenze hanno fatto una modifica E
questa vernice oggi è una grande
capacità antibatterica e quindi a breve
noi saremo in grado di verniciare le
nostre auto i nostri ospedali le nostre
scuole le nostre case i nostri mezzi
pubblici con questa vernice e far
trovare vita molto più difficile nella
proliferazione hai batteri E quindi
anche ai virus Ma poi vedete in piena
pandemia tanti si sono posti il problema
della Salute la genetica ha fatto un
salto da gigante oggi sequenziare il
Genoma Umano di una persona significa
Spendere meno di 1.000 dollari e
affrontare e approcciare Le patologie da
una prospettiva completamente diversa
Ma poi spesso arrivano innovazioni
contaminate da altri settori pensate nel
settore militare
l'esercito americano commissione è
un'azienda La costruzione di un
esoscheletro per poter catturare Bin
Laden in Pakistan questa azienda lo fa
poi questo esoscheletro viene
leggermente modificato e oggi Aiuta le
persone disabili a riacquisire la
mobilità Alice di 16 anni italiana il 21
luglio del 2019 indossa per la prima
volta questo esoscheletro lei avrebbe
avuto una vita solo in sedia a rotelle e
fa i suoi primi passi e poi mi verrebbe
da dire ma si tratta di tecnologia
Chiedetelo ad Alice
Ecco io sono entrato con un esoscheletro
che viene mutuato invece per il mondo
del lavoro Grazie a questo esoscheletro
attivandolo io acquisisco una forza
sulle mani o sulle gambe per poter fare
operazioni pesanti ma perché sono
entrato con queste esoscheletro per
significare solo un concetto che quando
integri la macchina con l'uomo non c'è
macchina può essere umano che possa
battere questo connubio Questo è il
connubio vincente
poi un altro aspetto importante in piena
pandemia ha preso piede finalmente
accelerato la telemedicina noi oggi
grazie a uno smartphone è un
collegamento internet siamo in grado di
tenerci sotto controllo la pressione di
misurarci il battito cardiaco di
controllarci nei di tenerci sotto
controllo la capacità respiratoria di
tenerci sotto controllo la nostra
ossigenazione di pesarci di controllarci
la febbre
di tenere sotto controllo il nostro
Tasso glicemico di farsi un'ecografia a
distanza Questa non è fantascienza
esiste già oggi
Ma poi
un'azienda italiana prende molti di
questi sensori li introduce all'interno
di una maglietta e oltre a tenere sotto
controllo questi parametri questa
maglietta in grado di rilasciare in
tempo reale un elettrocardiogramma 12
derivazione Questa non è tecnologia
Questo è un salvavita come un salvavita
lo è un robot che sviluppa un italiano
all'estero gli dà un nome italiano
totalmente italiano da Vinci perché la
chirurgia robotica il futuro perché è
molto più precisa molto meno invasiva e
soprattutto auto apprendente pensate Qui
sta pelando un picco d'uva e sopra
siccome Il Chicco d'Uva lo pela talmente
preciso che non rompe la pelle la sta
riattaccando dandogli dei punti di
sutura Ma la cosa più incredibile è
quella che non si vede perché Il Chicco
d'Uva si trovava a Trento e dottor
giulianotti lo stava operando a Los
Angeles stanno iniziando i primi
interventi a distanza questo non è solo
magia questo non è solo opportunità è
sostenibilità finiranno i viaggi della
speranza
per andare a cercare il medico migliore
posso rimanere nel mio paese
e vedete la realtà può essere vista in
tutti i modi come qualcosa di
impossibile che non accadrà mai oppure
come qualcosa che se lo faccio cadere
potrà cadere Beh se siamo di fronte alla
più grande riconversione industriale
Possiamo anche dire perché tutto questo
è generato da qualcuno che lo sta
pensando che non siamo di fronte alla
stessa rigenerazione professionale io
sostengo che non bisogna mai smettere di
imparare perché sennò si diventa presto
obsoleti ho fatto uno studio su quelli
che sono i lavori del futuro e dopo
averlo fatto l'ho buttato via perché
perché non c'è nessuno che può prevedere
il futuro e poi credo che non sia
neanche interessante credo che sia più
interessante capire quali sono le
competenze che servono per fare questi
lavori e li ho definiti nelle 5 i dove
la prima ieri evidentemente Ognuno di
noi deve conoscere qualcosa sulle
information technology perché se no non
si va più da nessuna parte
Paradossalmente anche in piena pandemia
un nonno non poteva comunicare con la
sua famiglia e quindi anche una
questione di
poi in questo mondo senza darsi Senza
Confini ma soprattutto senza barriere Ci
vuole un Passepartout e Il Passepartout
ci dobbiamo rendere conto che non l'ho
deciso io che è l'inglese e poi c'è la
terza i e la terza ia è molto importante
perché proprio Nell'era dell'information
Technology Nell'era dell'intelligenza
artificiale nell'era dei robot
come nel deserto ho bisogno di acqua
perché non c'è nell'era di queste
tecnologie io avrò bisogno della terza E
di intelligenza emotiva cioè dei veri
esseri umani non quelli che fanno le
cose che fanno le macchine che le fanno
meglio a minor costo Ma quelli che
mettono in campo le uniche
caratteristiche che una macchina un
intelligenza artificiale non potrà mai
avere
la coscienza la capacità di creare
E tutto questo di conseguenza genera la
quarta i che secondo me è un po' quella
che genera il tutto la quarta i ho fatto
uno studio che ha scoperto il nulla Ma
pensate che le principali aziende al
mondo di oggi cioè le più grandi non
esistevano 30 anni fa
sono state tutte costruite da ragazzi
che avevano meno di 30 anni
nessuno di questi ragazzi era figlio di
papà
Peccato che il 95% siano americane il 5%
asiatiche ce n'è uno europeo nessuno
italiano
perché perché abbiamo smesso non
sappiamo farlo
Probabilmente perché per fare qualcosa
di importante di grande bisogna prima
sognarlo e chi lo sogna e colui che ha
una mentalità imprenditoriale e quindi
la mentalità imprenditoriale non vuol
dire fare l'imprenditore vuol dire
affrontare la vita con la quinta e che
la più importante di tutte perché la
quinta i è una semplice i che sta per te
Cioè non lasciare più agli altri in mano
Il Timone ma prenditelo tu diventa
protagonista del cambiamento
io nel mio piccolo lo sto facendo Perché
mio nonno con la terza elementare Mi ha
sempre detto una cosa per cambiare il
mondo sembra impossibile ma c'è L'unico
modo che io conosco per farlo è con
l'esempio facendo le cose e poi come
posso finire un intervento che parla di
genetica di tecnologia di innovazione di
robot di intelligenza artificiale di
metaverso senza dire che in realtà c'è
qualcosa di molto più importante
che noi ancora facciamo che ci
dimentichiamo Ma che la scienza e la
tecnologia non solo non è stata in grado
di rifare ma non è neanche stato in
grado di spiegare perché vedi un giorno
tuo papà
ha incontrato tua mamma quel giorno
dentro al corpo di quell'ingegnere
perfetto che si chiama donna si è creata
un'altra vita che in nove mesi Io avevo
fretta in 7 è diventata talmente
perfetta che ha avuto il coraggio di
venire alla luce
e quando questa Robina qua viene alla
luce come Chiama ancora oggi nel 2022 la
scienza questo fenomeno Il miracolo
della vita e allora senza falsa retorica
Facciamoci una domanda se siamo in grado
di fare questo miracolo volete che non
siamo in grado di risolvere un problema
come quello della pandemia o di una
crisi economica che ne deriverà Einstein
diceva che tutto ciò che la mente umana
può pensare la può anche realizzare è
solo questione di tempo e di capire come
ma qui arriva la fregatura del come non
lo capiscono quelle persone che la
mattina si alzano piangendosi addosso
cercando i problemi criticando tutto
criticando tutti lamentandosi Questi
sono i rompiscatole che la vita ci mette
di fianco e fanno rumore ma Ricordiamoci
che nella stessa mattina c'è un numero
di persone nettamente superiore che si
sveglia in silenzio che si tira sulle
maniche e cerca la soluzione almeno uno
di quei problemi e quelle persone sono
di nuovo di una prima categoria quelli
che fanno un mestiere per passione e la
grande notizia è che un mestiere per
passione non lo potrà mai fare un robot
non lo potrà mai fare una macchina e
allora solo quelli che sono così foglie
da pensare di cambiare il mondo lo
cambiano davvero e oltre il confine ci
porterà sole e soltanto l'essere umano
Grazie
[Musica]